by the way I know you guys just did a
horror movie and I guess Charlie says is
also sort of A Hard movie right you've
done some dark [ __ ] mostly dark mostly
dark [ __ ] Kyle you've done a ton of
horror movies I mean dude haunting of
Connecticut Jennifer's Body nightmare in
Elm Street screen like my favorites of
my era that I went to the movies and saw
screw you're a scream King
it's a cool thing by the way Jennifer's
Body who is in that Megan Fox Megan Fox
how was it working with Megan Fox
um it was good you know it was it was
there was a part of it that like my
heart kind of broke for her every day
because it was smack in
Megan Fox pandemonium where everybody
was just like
so all over her that you could tell she
was like so guarded guarded in it and it
sucked because she was being sort of
just like objectified as a person by
everybody all by the world that it it
that was hard but she was very nice to
me
um
I had a good time working with her
um I actually had a really good time on
that movie that was basically one where
you want to talk about showing up and
I mean I I read for
uh Johnny Simmons role to be the
boyfriend and I didn't get it so they
just offered me Colin and I just showed
up and did the voice with all that weird
[ __ ] and they had never seen it what did
they say and I I did that first take and
Karen came up to me and she was just
like
just do it again I was like oh [ __ ] like
it was it was pretty trippy but no man
Megan was Megan was great I I enjoyed
working with her and I'm really happy to
see that that movie is actually kind of
getting a second
life yeah absolutely it was such a great
movie yeah did you guys see the
Woodstock 99 dock yes so can you believe
that's how 99 like that's when I was
like um don't say eight or something I
was born in 92 so seven but that's how
people treated women like just that
recently it was horrible it was awful
it's like they were just for the taking
it is horrible and some of those bands
just when you watch it just piss me off
how they got it going I know it was it
was hard to watch well yeah but just I
mean I'm thinking about how when did you
shoot that movie Kyle oh boy I that was
years ago early like early I did that
right after haunting Connecticut and I
turned 21 on the holiday in Connecticut
so I was probably 20
two but like what year I don't know what
was that never mind I found it 2 000. A
Little Ferry but I'm guessing 04
2009 okay still bad I mean I don't think
that like like you know what I mean that
era was just so women were so
objectified in like like an almost
insane way like there was no decorum
about it it was just like grab titties
and ah you know what I mean so anyways I
can't imagine this unfortunately yeah